ضربه اوكرانيه تستهدف ساداك خوفك
الاستراتيجي في منطقه خرسون التي تسيطر
عليها روسيا
ولاحقت به اضرار وفق وكاله انباء روسيه
هذا هو نقلت وكاله الانباء عن اجهزه
الطوارئ انا ستت الصواريخ اطلقت تم اسقاط
5 منها من قبل وحدات الدفاع الجوي الروسي
فيما اصاب صاروخ احد اقفل السد لكنه لم
يلحق به اضرار خطيره وفق المسؤول في
الاداره المعنيه في موسكو هذا ويؤمن سدك
خوفك الكهرومائي في جنوب اوكرانيا المياه
التي ضمتها موسكو في الاسابيع القليله
الماضيه حذرت اوكراني من ان موسكو تعتزم
نصف المنشق لاستراتيجيه للتسبب في فيضان
المدمر الامر الذي جعلك يبتدع الى نشر
بعثه دوليه في منطقته كما اعلنت السلطات
الروسيه ايضا ان مدينه خيرسون التي مازال
يحتلها الجيش الروسي رغم تقدم لقوتك في
الاسابيع اخيرا من دون كهرباء وماء وذلك
بعد غاره اوكرانيه اصاب خطوط الكهرباء
ممثل اجهزه الطوارئ في خرسون اكد انا اكثر
من 10 بلدات في المنطقه حاليا من دون
كهرباء حسب الاداره الاقليميه التي نصبتها
موسكو انه تم ارسال فني كهرباء الى موقع
القصف لاصلاح البنيه التحتيه